hey Brianne hi great that's my name you
wanna watch an honest trailer for thor
ragnarok I would love to watch an honest
trailer for Ragnarok oh this reminds me
I would have really appreciated the
other week two weeks ago when I was on
movie fights I would have really
appreciated it if I had remembered Jeff
Goldblum being the villain so that way I
could have said when he asked me like
who's gonna be the villain in this
Avengers Lady Avengers movie I could
have said Jeff Goldblum messed up I'm si
you know maybe you should learn to deal
with the pressure of a live studio crew
and a live thousands of audience members
while trying to remember all the
information and then being asked to
improvise something from how Rudnick you
should learn to deal with the pressure I
need to practice more but I don't have
opportunities to practice more people
don't give them to me we got make your
own I got it that's why I have my own
show anyway throw a ragnarok I wanted to
mention this one more time because
brands gonna be there a lot of people
you know will be there John Humphrey and
I are gonna be doing a live movie trivia
Schmo down match we're going up against
the wild berries you guys know them okay
and there was like I know there's like a
match afterwards that's like a big deal
is it but we're the ones another that's
loud
[Music]
Gary ran for Marvel Studios new logo is
still going alright ah wait
[Music]
[Music]
geez how long is this thing just cut it
off nobody has time for that
right now we're running behind it's Thor
the Ragnarok after the dark world Wallis
track with a radical new formula for the
Thor pills not making them suck stolen
all the dead weight of the franchise
from his love interest to his home way
to its fringe you couldn't name with a
gun to your head to his right eye to his
dad his hair and even his hammer they
stripped all the weight off huh it's
like the whole franchise got on his
worth the steamed chicken diet and said
meet Thor god of thunder who despite
being able to shoot lightning from his
hands it's been supposed to the film
getting electrocuted
[Music]
Rachel responder luke skywalker's
himself into the afterlife
his sister hella goddess of pointy
things a church family view that will
make you wonder are we sure it or wasn't
the adopted would put it next to hella
Loki and young Anthony Hawkins until
he's not the odd got out real enemy
director Tycho ytt takes the reigns of a
giant superhero movie because when
you're part of a 14 billion dollar
global franchise YTM not now it's out
with the old and in with the jokes
be home must stop we're going exposition
scenes get tagged by jokes mountains and
very my sword
it was a badass movements get tagged by
jokes jokes
yeah they overdo it sometimes but this
is a movie where an orgy spaceship
shoots fireworks over the Rainbow Bridge
where hope fights a zombie wolf if
you're mad at tries to make you laugh
too
you're doing it follow Thor's Exile on
sac are a collection of the galaxy's
most colorful gladiators garbage and
gold boobs first
and thrill as it turns into the closest
thing your kids will fight at home
picture where Bruce Banner awakens to
finally spent the last two years of his
life as an asleep killing machine and
take all that 90 minutes to get over it
venture together they'll come up with
you introduced to the throne averse like
the depressant alcoholic Valkyrie thanks
I take away from
rods nose forearms warrior 3 dodged that
bullet lady SIF but don't worry you
still got it coming enjoy the first
Marvel bill where everything actually
looks like a classic Marvel comic book
that reminds us all the where's the
cosmic FICA greeted by nerds on acid in
the 60s it should click crazy with the
best bridge sequence it's dead ruled the
best team a laser fights and Starship
Troopers and a Miko chase sequence when
the hero jumps have to take the bad guys
down by head start it's all the other
ones
[Music]
hey we found marbles this guy being yeah
absolutely but what would be also the
best Hulk movie probably the best Doctor
Strange movie the second-best Guardians
movie and she probably the best in that
movie we're ever going to get to that
hopefully talk Marvel in an orgy lesson
don't fire the weirdo embrace it embrace
that weirdo lord
yah-yah-yah actual Jeff Goldblum for the
Horde Ben dim someone give this woman an
untitled standalone movie and all the
time they were able to get out her cell
before she's so thorny george RR martin
sure contractually locked into a cameo
[Laughter]
and gore the 4d experience coming summer
2022 Disney's California Adventure Flash
Gordon look at some clever eyes
note to self before commissioning the
propaganda mural depicting my peaceful
rise to power
don't Commission another mural depicting
the horrible horrible truth and the
Oscar for Best Picture goes to the fish
baby
so that's it huh we are just some kind
of Justice League my stripper name is
sugar dust what Conda or ever nice nice
nice
you know the fighting on top of cars or
moving ship I've not ever put that
together actually I thought there's just
an action movie thing that happens they
were showing like all the different
times marble has done it themselves I
was like oh wow they're right this is a
thing that does go on like an action
movie thing
my thought of one was like the matrix -
yeah when they're fighting on the
freeway yeah yeah the Matrix Reloaded
even the star trek into darkness when
they Benedict Cumberbatch and Zachary
they're fighting each other that's what
I was thinking of when it was happening
maybe you'd like the electrocution he's
been electrocuted all the time or bit
great point about what they said with
are they sure Thor's not the adopted one
even they do that side by side with Loki
hella and young Anthony Hopkins he does
look like the odd man out the whole time
that would be a great twist reveal but
where'd he come from then I really liked
the honest roads also pointed out -
about embracing the weirdo that was a
really big upset to me what happened
with Edgar Wright leaving at man knows
something I was really looking forward
to I thought it would add a really
unique flair there so some of Edgar
Wright's touches minorly sprinkled in
throughout the film
what tiger / TT did with this movie that
gives me hopes that they can keep doing
the weird stuff slow movie neon-lit
randomly violence for me personally I
want a musical superhero movie that
needs to be coming who will be the group
with the guardians of the galaxy all I
know is that Black Widow is a trained
ballerina so I feel like she should be
dancing somewhere in there that's the
main one you want maybe you should take
your lady lady Marvel character fire
thing you pitched on movie fights to
turn into a musical I could turn it into
musical but I feel like well let's give
them a chance for people to want to see
it on the DC shows for like flash and
yeah they've done the musical episode
and it kind of worked you know kind of
work your to guess the other thing the
other main complaint I would kind of
agree with this they could have dialed
down the jokes just a tad bit in Thor
Ragnarok cuz it is kind of a joke every
like 10 seconds there are moments in the
trailer specifically two that were
teased that look like this will be like
the epic part all that stuff was
searcher was
really dumb down for joke purposes in
the very beginning and even at the end
when a Hulk is going after him and
you're like no don't do that that could
have been one element to just have it be
a little bit more serious is I feel like
when you have some serious moments that
really land then the humor parts hit
even better I agree with comedy you know
well something's comedy learning ytt
but now this is one of Marvel's best
movies yeah this is this is a whole area
so and it does look like a Marvel comic
which is really cool all right well guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
subscribe to screen junkies while you're
at it - Brienne Chandler on Miss movies
make sure to check her out it'll be well
worth it trust me trust me what am I
gonna go back on who's your guest
tomorrow we don't have a guest tomorrow
you're welcome to come on tomorrow oh
god I just don't have the time tomorrow
we're just--we're tomorrow we're
creating musicals like Oh haven't been
made I really don't have the time
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's how I roll I like to open the
door and shut it myself